oui bienvenue à part à l'autochtone ici
c'est melissa maulin du put alors cette
semaine je me suis trouvé un petit coin
de paradis
avec un peu de soleil de la chaleur en
se prêtant qui est particulièrement
froid et se fait froid dehors n'est pas
pour alléger notre situation en temps de
crise du coc bild cependant pour me
réchauffer le coeur je suis allé sur les
médias ce sera encore une fois et j'ai
pu être témoin d'initiatives
communautaires dans les communautés
autochtones du sud de l'amérique jusqu'à
au canada et un peu partout on voit
justement cet aspect communautaire de
toutes les différentes nations
autochtones ressortir dans une période
telle que le coc vide de 19 et je veux
particulièrement subi certains des
aspects qui touchent le québec parce que
on le voit présentement sur tous les
points de presse que la situation à
montréal la situation en région est
totalement différente
cependant on va rajouter une autre
différence si on parle des situations de
communauté autochtone et là je pense
beaucoup à des communautés qui sont
éloignés qu'ils vont avoir fermé aussi
la leur leurs portes et leurs frontières
pour pouvoir permettre un isolement
total à la communauté et ainsi prévenir
justement des éclosions de cotco vide
dans des mairies dans des communautés
qui sont souvent en difficulté
d'approvisionnement de logements pour
les familles nombreuses et pour la
simple et bonne raison que justement on
a souvent des problématiques au niveau
des maladies pulmonaires et on veut
protéger notre population la plus à
risque est la plus précieuse à nos yeux
culturellement c'est à dire nos aînés
alors que quand on regarde à montréal et
bien là on voit une autre situation
surtout que montréal présentement se
trouve dans une position très fragile
par rapport au corps aux éclosions de
qu'ovide sur son territoire mais là tu
rajoute le fait que à montréal d'une
population autochtone très présente et
particulièrement des fois des
populations très vulnérable alors on va
enlever des initiatives qui ont sorti
pour les personnes qui sont qui ont des
besoins de première ligne comme les
personnes qui sont en situation
d'itinérance les femmes les familles qui
ont parfois malheureusement à faire face
à de la violence conjugale qui est
accrue présentant à tous les niveaux
pendant la crise du convive vu leur
enfermement dans les maisons dans les
foyers alors en offrant ses services de
première ligne
certains des éléments communautaires les
plus importants deviennent des
organismes des centres d'amitié des
regroupements communautaires qu'on a pu
voir avant des projets extraordinaires
je pense particulière dans le cas de
montréal a résilié ans montréal qui ont
fait des pas ni préparer de la
nourriture des repas chaud surtout en
cette situation de froid extrême pour
justement la population en reste après
un peu plus à son premier de première
ligne et devenir un fort justement pour
des services qui peuvent s offrir aux
premières nations aux communautés inuit
alors que c'est si des fonds totalement
dans un temps normal à discuter a accédé
ajustement des services de deux de
premiers soins de première ligne donc
résilience montréal fait un travail
extraordinaire et ce qui est
extraordinaire à danser de voir la
mobilisation la population pour faire
monter des fonds faire des donations
on a vu des gens qui ont fait de la
banique qui ont fait du chili
et tout ça avec l'énergie la
mobilisation communautaire de montréal
je pense aussi au centre d'un mythique
sont dans d'autres villes comme par
exemple leçon d'amitié de lanaudière qui
ont préparé des paniers des sacs
d'activités pour les enfants
parce que quand on est pris dans une
situation d'enfermement dans un
appartement mais qu'on a des cinq six
enfants et bien avoir ces sacs
d'activités là pour pour continuer
l'école à la maison pour amuser à avoir
un passant pour ces enfants là c'est
extraordinaire mais j'ai aussi vu des
repas pas c'est que j'avais dit je
mangerais bien de ce petit repas alors
d'amener cette challenge communautaire a
beaucoup de gens qui sont éloignés de
leurs communautés
puisqu'ils peuvent pas accéder alors à
leur famille qui habituellement sont
accessibles par exemple lanaudière ça va
être
les communautés atikamekw bien
restaurant leur comme un resserrement
des communautés ils ne peuvent pas
accéder à leur filet social habituel qui
vont les aider justement à passer à
travers les fins de mois ou même juste
du support moral d'avoir une grand mère
qui vient garder une fin de semaine pour
une maman ça peut être extraordinaire
mais malheureusement il faut s'adapter à
la situation de distanciation social
qu'on voit en ce moment et c'est panier
là j'ai vu aussi qu'il cueillait de la
médecine traditionnelle pour les aînés
qui sont pris à lanaudière donc il ya
lieu extrêmement une réflexion qui a été
fait autour des projets et des besoins
directs des communautés des familles et
qu'on pense aux communautés éloignées
très éloignées je regarde toujours dans
mon village qu'est ce qui se fait et
moins une des initiatives que j'ai
vraiment été touché c'est de voir que
les femmes au centre culturel innu de
mes gars ont cousu plus de 600 masque en
tissu pour chacun des membres de la
communauté
donc ils ont fait des masques pour les
adultes et pour les enfants
comme ça si jamais un masque était
nécessaire pour aller avoir des soins de
santé pour devons faire l'épicerie à
l'extérieur de la communauté
eh bien ces masques on a vu aussi des
paniers pour les parents on a vu du
support communautaire on a vu aussi
s'adapter adapter ses politiques par
rapport aux besoins alimentaires des
communautés donc comme on respectait
beaucoup la distanciation social dans la
communauté
on a adapté les règles de distanciation
social pour permettre justement aux
chasseurs de la communauté d'aller
chercher des auteurs puisque c'était la
période de la chasse mais vraiment
c'était un modèle je pense de leadership
est aussi un modèle de rassemblement
communautaire derrière un cas qui nous
concerne tous pour pouvoir aller
justement le poids du moment pour le
reste la communauté ceux qui peuvent
malheureusement pas être dans une action
directe ou qu'ils doivent penser à leurs
enfants qu'ils doivent penser à leur
maladie et qui ne peuvent pas être aussi
actifs qu'ils le sont habituellement
donc les initiatives communautaires sont
extraordinairement
utile plus qu'elles sont directement
liés aux besoins immédiats
malheureusement qu'on voit des
politiques plus provincial ou fédéral
on voit soit des politiques qui veulent
être très active mais qui ne vise pas
directement le besoin immédiat et ça
c'est le travail de la communauté c'est
le travail d'avoir les yeux tournés vers
les membres de sa communauté et de se
préoccuper du bien-être de sa communauté
donc n'hésitez pas à visiter justement
les sites de facebook ou le site web de
ces regroupements comme résilience
montréal les centres d'amitié les
regroupements les santiano partout au
québec et au canada et même des fois les
initiatives communautaires dans les
réserves où les communautés proches de
chez vous vous allez peut-être des fois
avoir des appels à l'action ce à dire
que vous nous envoyez des manteaux
d'hiver vous nous envoyez des chaussures
est ce que vous voulez faire des dons
pour pouvoir nourrir tel groupe ou de
faire des paniers alors là vous allez
pouvoir répondre à l'appel et aux
besoins directs de votre communauté
alors je souhaite une bonne semaine nous
encourageons regardez autour de vous
puis à vous assurer que votre communauté
et en santé